المدفعيه الروسيه تقصف بخموت بقوه ناريه
كثيفه كما تبينه صور الجيش الروسي الذي
اعلن السيطره على بلده صغيره قرب المدينه
فيما يقول مسؤولون في الجيش الاوكراني انه
تم تحصين المواقع
يحاولون صدنا وحصارنا كي نغادر المدينه
لكنهم لن ينجحوا بالطبع خسرنا الكثير
لكننا نتدبر امرنا وما زلنا نقاوم
بعد اشهر من القصف المدفعي قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها تقدمت بضعه
كيلومترات على طول الخطوط الاماميه مع
اعتراف كييف بان الوضع معقد في بخموت
الامين العام لمنظمه حلف شمال الاطلسي
اعترف بدوره ان روسيا اطلقت هجوما مضادا
وصفه بالقاتل هجوم يزيد حاجه القوات
الاوكرانيه للسلاح والذخيره ويزيد الضغط
على حلف الناتو
الحرب في اوكرانيا تستهلك كميات كبيره من
الذخيره وتستنزف مخزونات الحلفاء الوتيره
الحاليه لاستهلاك الذخيره اعلى من وتيره
الانتاج وهذا يزيد الضغط على صناعاتنا
الدفاعيه
وكان حلف الناتو قد رفع من قدرات انتاج
الذخيره بشكل كبير بالموازاه مع مقترحات
كي تقوم اوروبا بشراء الاسلحه والذخائر
وتسليمها الى اوكرانيا بشكل مباشر مقترح
سيكون على جدول اعمال اجتماع لوزراء
الدفاع لدول حلف شمال الاطلسي يوم
الثلاثاء